[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every night
you know it's crazy
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tear gas canisters grow back
[Music]
I'm 10:30 and in and with the elastic
runnin runnin and runnin an inland
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're gonna so now we're underneath
the we're in
yeah we're inside the parking garage now
so at least nothing can hit us from
above there's a bottle it just landed a
few feet from the from the officers
that's right so they're yeah the police
officers that were it's the police at
this point who are backing up not the
demonstrators the police are backing
away they were the ones that were behind
that shield and they were just ten or
twelve feet away from the first line of
demonstrators but now they're backing
away so
[Applause]
so the tear gas is drifting our way once
again I'm gonna watch the images here
while well I well I back away and get a
breath of fresh air I like to watch the
images here and let you know as soon as
as soon as uh there's a development here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey teddy
hey teddy there's an officer over there
that's bent over because he's suffering
the effects of uh see the officer right
there
but suffering the effect on and he was
bent over
on his knees feeling the effects of the
tear gas as well so stump but not all of
the officers out here have gas masks so
if the gas does there he went down he
went down on his knees once again so
with the gas when it drips back into the
the police line it does it affect them
as well you can see these officers look
then bent over
you
president of the Baptist ministers
conference my old friends pastor William
smart bishop
Juan Carlos Mendes and pastor Michael
Fisher jr. who's here with me tonight
and many others and before anybody who's
friends with them say anything to them
they gave me a good hard time they were
demanding about justice as everyone in
America should be right now
and like so many others who were
peacefully protesting we need to hear
those voices and I want to lift one of
those up tonight and I would just ask
cut away when I come back if you need to
but I would ask our television stations
to give the voice on the evening news to
a young black male Angelino because at
the end of the day this story is about
the pain that people carry the day that
they are born from the traumas visited
on their ancestors and from the first
moment they're taller than a cute little
boy the way they're looked at in our
society I'm gonna ask a young man of
faith and of inspiration who I met today
Davian pilgrim a 16 year old student
from Morningside High School who told me
his story and I want you to hear his
story to talk about what this moment and
this movement means so Davian thank you
so much for being with us this
microphone in this city is yours
hi my name is Devi on pilgrim and I am
sixteen years old I went first I want to
say thank you to Mary Garcetti for give
me the opportunity to speak today
because I have a story to share
I was recently stopped by the police
officers and racially and criminally
profile I was accused of being like
being associated with the gang I thought
that really hurt because that's not me I
am a god-fearing young black man I'm an
athlete
I'm a president of the youth department
graders are in church in Compton on the
leadership dr. marcoh JT Fisher I love
God that's why I believe in a change and
I have hope this the opportunities with
the people of faith I have a
conversation with the mayor today was
hopeful we want to make sure that what
happens to George Flo Floyd does not
ever happen again to someone that just
looks like me lose our lives to the
police officers one of the biggest fears
that we have in South LA I have seven
brothers and sisters and I for surely
don't want none of that to happen to
them this is a horror moment but the
good news is that there is still time
for unity and while I think we should
keep protesting and demanding change
there is no need to loot and tear our
things down it is time for us to rebuild
conversations is our what we need we
need to talk to each other we need to
understand each other the police needs
to understand what we are coming from it
is my prayer my deep prayer that we come
together in unity and when we take a
stand together at a time like this we
need to hold our officers accountable
and we must stay strong for change and
for peace thank you amen
thank you Dave young they could view the
courage of this moment and for the
courage of your generation justice is
never given it is earned it is earned by
the chapters we see written on the
streets of our country
sometimes with people's bodies and
always with the courage that they have
to move us forward so here's the
uncomfortable part tonight
it falls on leaders not to just say the
right things but to do the right things
after I left that meeting across the
street with the leaders from Baptist
community in the faith community I came
back and I listened to folks on my own
team I listened to a powerful young
black man who said that it's tough to
even work in government right now
another member of my team who said every
single time even though he works for the
mayor and carries a mayor's badge when
somebody rolls up behind him from law
enforcement
it makes him shudder and he's worried
about whether reaching for that badge to
reassure them might scare them more than
just sitting there until he can explain
who he is
I heard from April who was doing the
most amazing work housing Angelenos who
are unhand who's dealing with the pain
of this moment by taking things to folks
who are living in our shelters that
we've set up so she brought shoes to
them and all she could think about in
her mind was with a car full of shoes
well they think that I'm a looter I want
non-black Angelenos to hear those
stories and to have those conversations
have them in your workplace and in your
neighborhood have them in your church
and wherever you are if we don't
acknowledge that a black woman is four
times more likely to die because she
wants to bring a child into this world
than a white woman then we can't see
that if we don't see that if you're a
black man in Los Angeles you're ten
times more likely to
homeless than if you're a white man we
can't see that and while not every death
is as visible and as vicious as George
Floyd's we have to own those deaths that
come from the diabetes and that come
from kovat 19 and all of the things that
visit black Americans disproportionately
because of where they start life and
where this society values their life the
schools that they are born into in the
neighborhoods where they live that have
been discarded and efforts to fund those
schools rejected the moments in which we
see that racial justice can't be the
work of ten percent of a nation it has
to be the work of a hundred percent of
the nation so to my fellow Angelenos to
my african-american brothers and sisters
who live in this city I want to say I
hear you and I hear that this isn't just
about the criminal justice system this
is about also our society and where we
put our resources when we've done things
like raise the minimum wage and that
disproportionately hits women and
african-americans we have to see those
as important bricks in building this new
house when we do things like making
Community College free that contributes
to what we see with justice but we also
have from our budget which is a moral
document which needs to keep people safe
and protected but the best way for
people to be safe and protected and I
hear you on the street loud and clear is
not just by throwing dollars always into
police departments but also into youth
programs and into educational
opportunities and into trauma based
recovery for people who carry trauma I
don't have announcements tonight but I
want you to know that I've been having
these conversations for the last two or
three days I'm having them with my
fellow elected officials I'm having them
with community leaders I'm having them
with young people who are demanding that
I and we collectively do better that
just as after the trauma of 1992 we
emerged Ford was saying never again
- things like legalized chokeholds which
killed black men in this city never
again - no independent investigations
when there's acts of police brutality
and never again too many things we must
ask what are the never again moments
today and I look forward in the next day
or two and with mayor's across the
country who I've been having this
conversation with to make sure that we
build from this moment that we here from
this moment that we fund from this
moment that we look at the prism of race
in America as one of the greatest sins
that we have had and one that stays with
us and that we can only get past when we
all get past that together that's my
simple pledge to you tonight as we look
at what has been a safer day and a more
beautiful day I look forward to the day
when we get rid of a curfew when we
don't have national guard when our
police officers don't have their helmets
on and I want to make
you
folks who break into businesses we will
go after people who are looting or worse
causing violence against demonstrators
or to peace officers but let's put that
here and not let that dominate what this
moment and this movement is about
because if we let that be the only image
if we let that be the only story we are
missing our opportunity and this isn't
going to go away soon it will only go
away when there is the trust that we are
taking the actions to build a summer of
peace this summer in Los Angeles and
across the country with jobs for young
people with peaceful places to be with a
mental health care that we need to deal
with what that feels like day after day
after day to be a young black man who
doesn't know why people don't trust him
look at him that way feel that way every
moment they inhabit a body
somebody powerfully said to me today I'm
an ally but at the end of the day I can
turn off my phone I can stop looking at
Twitter I can watch some TV but for my
black brothers and sisters they can't
turn that off they can't stop being
black they can't stop being seen by the
racism that still pervades our country
there is so much work for us to do and I
am so proud of this city I know that
those those who just want to focus on
the law and order and I know it is my
responsibility to throw everything I
have into peace restoration and building
in this city but that doesn't just
happen from peace officers that happens
from our investments in communities and
in neighborhoods whether or not we say
to folks who have been involved in the
criminal justice system instead of
you're done with your time but there's
no help here's a job and here's a way
forward for us to look at what's our
fight with kovat 19 now is about and
please please please everybody who's
been out there protesting so beautifully
around Los Angeles make sure you get
tested and make sure you're maintaining
your physical distance that you're
washing your hands and wearing a mask
imagine if these days lead to a spread
that leads to things getting worse and
more people dying please go to
coronavirus LA City org
testing and get a test not only did we
have Dodger Stadium open we're reopening
the Crenshaw Christian Center site three
or four sites that can do thousands and
thousands of tests to meet the capacity
that we need because we have to defeat
that threat to us all which does
discriminate disproportionately against
communities of color let me just take a
breath to say we aren't where we once
were but we aren't where we need to be
we're maybe stuck somewhere in the
middle of the mountain in this nation in
this city's history if you're young all
you can see is up and how far we have to
go to reach the peak and you should be
unyielding and demanding that we keep
climbing and for some of us who have
been around who have seen the changes
who have worked hard to bring about
things like implicit bias training and
de-escalation in our police force or to
look at the ways that summer night
lights and our gang reduction youth
development programs came out of demands
from the community to say parks need to
be places of peace for the summer and
for our children that helped us get up
the mountain and we can look down and
see how far we've come we have two
choices Los Angeles either hopelessness
that this is a moment that can't be
fixed that America is so broken that we
can't repair our hearts and we can't
repair our streets and we can't bring
peace to our lives or we have hope the
only thing that has ever guided this
country our city and our world we all
know or many of us know the Negro
national anthem and I want to quote from
it in the first verse it and sing us a
song full of the faith that the dark
past has taught us sing a song full of
the hope that the present has brought us
and facing the Rising Sun of our nude
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're not only happy
stay depressed what if I ask you what
you saw happening bro they grabbed
innocent people for no reason and
decided like Kaufmann and pushing him to
the ground
this dude was a he's a journalist and
the press he has a press pass and they
pushed him to the ground
did something happen I saw but there are
people dancing they were chanting nobody
nobody did anything seem like most of
the group I walked away and then I
turned around and so you might if I ask
what your name is
Andre my shows you teleport me and BR e
mb r CH BR
you
[Music]